but a while back there was a situation
where Logan Paul was asked who he would
want to fight next and he threw out
Antonio Browns name recently Antonio
Brown responded and said that he'd be
down to fight Logan Paul in a boxing
match and Logan Paul said that he would
drop him faster than the Patriots so now
they want to do a box all to me I've got
a why I mean I don't know but I'm
telling you Brown would have to train
for a while but I mean that's a very
different athlete odd shark right there
I don't think Logan Paul's ever fought
an athlete like that what are you what
are your thoughts on that Brendan Schaub
you just know how much of a freak
athlete Antonio Brown please anybody
please give us him I love this [ __ ] I
love this so please give us some some of
your thoughts on this cuz Antonio Brown
I don't think Logan Paul even
understands how fast and Tonio Browns
hands are what kind of an athlete is
what do you have to do to get Intel
you're brown to stop will you talking
about point
oooo one of all football players make it
to the NFL level point
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh one are all
pros then point oh one our [ __ ] Hall
of Famers
that'd be Antonio Brown so it's just
different
have you seen like a lean forward flip
yeah it's just aliens 510 185 look at
Paul 62 190 look was a big kid but yeah
Antonia Brown I would imagine if he
starts this is where you're getting in a
weird world like you know Logan Paul is
a buddy of mine I like Logan Paul like
what do you represent stuff like that
he's made a career for himself but this
is where the lines get a little blurred
here you know yeah just when you fight
when we start another youtuber that
makes sense you're frightened not like
an amateur fighter alright whatever but
when you start call it like real real
athletes you know it gets a little funky
yeah it's fun to talked about yeah you
know it you know it'd probably get views
and Tony around just he's still very
young still got speed
it's give him some just give him some
training how long is he good to train
for I don't know real this is this is
this will never happen
yeah you're taking it too serious
welcome calls it jacked [ __ ]
though he's definitely jacked you see
you ever seen that tire brow now now one
of them is a youtuber we love him and
then one led the NFL in catches the NFL
but he got some speed though oh there is
yeah yeah yeah good one where he's
flexing there you go yeah now one is
factually crazy yet every NFL team is
trying to still work for them are they
still is he gonna play again I don't
know is he being is he being me the same
problem in for workup oh they did yep I
don't think they signed them really and
they and they lost because of it damn
that's super jacked yeah he that's my
house yeah he's a thick boy he's
probably got some help that's that's a
big kiss that a nipples on him that like
one yeah yeah one big ass did you
wrestle in college you tell me that high
school high school junior college mmm
cuz I mean he's making millions doing
YouTube yes edit-a-thon uh-huh yeah he's
big kid good guy man tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]